Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，这些原则都同样适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode.
挑战中还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导时间。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Durant Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I want to start this episode in a slightly different way because I want to make sure that you are looking after yourselves. Today's episode features trauma and thinking about the way that we can work with people experiencing trauma or who have experienced trauma as aspiring psychologists. And it's okay for you to make the choice not to listen to this episode if you feel that to do so would trigger you. Perhaps you are not in the current headspace, you know, where you have the ability to think about this stuff. And it's not to say that you will always feel that way, but if today you're feeling actually this rubs up against
如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南吧。欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我想以一种略有不同的方式开始这期节目，因为我想确保你们都在照顾好自己。今天的话题涉及创伤，以及作为有抱负的心理学家，我们该如何与经历过创伤的人一起工作。如果你觉得听这期节目会触动你的创伤，你可以选择不听。也许你现在的心理状态并不适合思考这些问题。这并不是说你永远都会这样，但如果今天你觉得这些内容触碰到了
some of your own stuff or some stuff that feels really painful. Of course, I'm going to be handling it in a compassionate way using my qualified opinions, advice and guidance. But it's OK for you to choose to look after yourself. If this does sit a little bit too closely to home, you can give yourself permission to come back to this at a future time when you feel like you'll be better resourced to be able to engage with the content without it evoking painful stuff for you that might feel overwhelming right now so I wanted to just give you that option and the the full informed disclosure really that this might feel like a trickier episode than some of the past ones that I have done okay I am very much looking forward to talking with you to help you think about this really useful and interesting area, which we have so much value to bring.
你内心深处的一些东西，或者让你感到非常痛苦，请记住，我当然会以富有同情心的方式，运用我的专业意见、建议和指导来处理这些内容。但如果你觉得这太贴近你的个人经历，你可以选择照顾好自己，给自己留出空间，等未来你觉得更有能力应对这些内容时再回来听，而不必让它引发让你感到难以承受的痛苦。我只是想给你这个选择，并进行充分的知情披露，这期节目可能比我过去做的一些节目更具挑战性。好的，我非常期待与你们探讨这个非常有价值且有趣的领域。
So, hi. Yeah, welcome along. Like I said in the little intro, the little caveat, today we are going to be thinking about working with trauma as an aspiring psychologist. And I won't go over everything I've just said in my little disclaimer, but just to say that it will be, you know, it will be useful stuff, but might feel, might feel, you know, gritty and raw and real, because course it is and you might be thinking oh no trauma I've got no interest in working with trauma perhaps you're thinking that you're going into a an area of psychology where trauma doesn't crop up as often and to you I would say in my experience trauma is everywhere and it impacts on all areas of society so actually I think it's
那么，你好。欢迎收听。正如我在开场白和免责声明中所说，今天我们将探讨作为有抱负的心理学家如何处理创伤。我不会重复刚才说的所有内容，只想说这些内容会很有用，但可能会让人感到有些沉重、真实和赤裸，因为事实本就如此。你可能会想：“哦不，创伤，我对处理创伤毫无兴趣。”也许你认为自己从事的心理学领域不会经常遇到创伤。对此，我想说，根据我的经验，创伤无处不在，它影响着社会的各个层面。所以实际上，我认为这是
one of the most interesting and relevant topics to cover because it's so unknown about even even within you know mental health services they're not all trauma informed and it can have such a massive impact um on on people and their lives and the you know choices and decisions that they make and the things that they've experienced so i hope you'll find it really useful um and especially if you're going into forensic psychology um it can be incredibly useful so what we know about it's a rudimentary measure called the ACE scale and what we know about about people on the ACE scale is that depending on their score, you know, people are more likely to experience a whole host of physical and mental health difficulties. So for example, people who score four and above on the
最有趣且最相关的话题之一，因为它在心理健康服务领域中甚至都未被充分了解。并非所有服务都具备“创伤知情”意识，而创伤对人们的生活、选择、决策以及他们所经历的一切都有巨大的影响。所以我希望你能觉得这很有用，特别是如果你打算从事法医心理学，这会非常有用。我们所知道的是一种基础测量工具，称为ACE量表（不良童年经历量表）。关于ACE量表，我们知道的是，根据得分的不同，人们更有可能经历一系列身心健康问题。例如，在ACE量表上得分4分及以上的人，
ACE scale are more likely to experience anxiety, depression, they're more likely to have things like migraines, IBS, they're more likely to be taking prescribed medication, unsubscribed medication and to be experimenting with drugs too. They're more likely to drink more alcohol units per week than people who score three and below on the scale. They're more likely to, you know, have a whole host of difficulties, including some spinal, disc, neck and back problems, including, I believe, some evidence that some heart conditions are more likely in people who score four and above. And of course, at the grand end of the scale, they're more likely to spend time in Her Majesty's prison. And so that's where the particular relevance comes in for forensic psychology. Because of course, what we're looking at is often a prison population full of traumatized
更容易经历焦虑、抑郁，更容易患上偏头痛、肠易激综合征（IBS），更容易服用处方药或非处方药，也更容易尝试毒品。与得分3分及以下的人相比，他们每周饮酒量更多。他们更有可能患上一系列疾病，包括脊柱、椎间盘、颈部和背部问题，我相信还有证据表明，得分4分及以上的人患某些心脏病的可能性更高。当然，在量表的极端情况下，他们更有可能在监狱中度过时光。这就是它与法医心理学特别相关的地方，因为我们所面对的往往是一个充满受过创伤的
people. And there's a really interesting book on this by Chris Dorr QC, who's one of my LinkedIn connections. And his book is called Justice on Trial. And I found it a really interesting read to help think about the justice system and how it might need a shake up. So if you wanted to do some reading kind of around this topic, but a non psychology stance, he's a QC. So, you know, yeah, he writes well. I listen to it on Audible because that's where I listen to my, you know, business books and clinical relevant books and stuff around that. And so I found that really interesting. So you might well find that useful, too, if you wanted to think some more about the justice system. And yeah, I liked his ideas on that. So hope you do find it useful if you do give it a go so this ace scale it um covers um it's 10 questions and it covers a number of different life areas so it covers sort of perceived threat in that all of these questions are the first 18 years of life so perceived threat actual physical threat and violence, parental separation, parental ill health through
人群的监狱。关于这一点，有一本非常有趣的书，作者是Chris Dorr QC，他是我LinkedIn上的联系人之一。他的书名为《审判中的正义》（Justice on Trial）。我发现这本书对于思考司法系统以及它为何需要改革非常有启发。所以，如果你想在心理学之外的领域阅读一些关于这个主题的内容，他是位御用大律师（QC），所以他写得很好。我是在Audible上听的，因为我通常在那里听商业书籍、临床相关书籍以及相关内容。我发现这非常有趣，如果你想深入思考司法系统，你可能会觉得它很有用。我喜欢他在这方面的观点，希望你尝试阅读后也会觉得有用。这个ACE量表包含10个问题，涵盖了不同的生活领域，所有这些问题都针对人生的前18年，包括感知到的威胁、实际的身体威胁和暴力、父母离异、因
mental health reasons, parental drug use, alcohol use, sexual abuse and a number of other factors but all of these will come out with someone's unique ACE score for their first 18 years of life. And it can be really useful to talk about people's ACE scores with them and to help them to understand, you know, the damaging impact that trauma can have on our our minds and our bodies so sometimes when i go through the evidence that um that you know that people are more likely to have migraines and ibs and you know spinal disc and neck back problems they're like oh it's like you're reading my medical history it's like you've been chatting with my gp I haven't but it feels like I have because they're described you know they're they're living a life of a traumatized person and this is what we know
心理健康原因导致的父母健康状况不佳、父母吸毒、酗酒、性虐待以及其他许多因素。所有这些都会得出一个人在人生前18年独特的ACE得分。与人们讨论他们的ACE得分，帮助他们理解创伤对我们的思想和身体造成的破坏性影响，是非常有用的。有时，当我列举那些证据，比如人们更容易患偏头痛、肠易激综合征、脊柱椎间盘和颈背问题时，他们会说：“天哪，你简直是在读我的病历，好像你和我的全科医生聊过一样。”我并没有，但感觉就像聊过，因为他们描述的正是受创伤者的生活，而这就是我们所知道的
happens to people who've been through you know prolonged trauma in their in their formative years and of course trauma does have a massive impact on people after the age of 18 as well but what we know is that it has a particular impact in terms of developmental trauma in the way that people form their beliefs about themselves the world and others around them from what they experience in their first 18 years it's really important that we know what a traumatized person looks like and what they'll be experiencing and what they'll be thinking. Because what I have found is that it doesn't actually take a super amount of adverse events to score those four points. So it might be that your parents separated, it might be that one of your parents had alcoholism and the other
发生在那些在成长岁月中经历过长期创伤的人身上的事情。当然，18岁以后的创伤也会对人产生巨大影响，但我们知道，它在发育性创伤方面有着特殊的影响，影响着人们根据前18年的经历，对自我、世界和周围他人形成信念的方式。了解受创伤的人是什么样子，他们正在经历什么，以及他们在想什么，这一点非常重要。因为我发现，其实并不需要发生特别多的负面事件就能达到那4分。可能只是因为你的父母离异了，可能其中一位父母有酗酒问题，而另一位
one had depression. And then it didn't maybe feel like your family were like other families, you know, that's your four points. And so many people are walking around living their lives not knowing that technically, you know, they might be experiencing some symptoms of developmental trauma. They might be spending their life feeling like, you know, I feel really anxious, I don life feeling like you know I feel really anxious I don't really know why I feel you know really depressed but we've got anything to be depressed about and so when they come into therapy for the first time and we think about developmental trauma it helps them join up the dots and helps make a lot of sense of that please don't think
有抑郁症。然后你可能觉得你的家庭不像其他家庭那样，这就是你的4分。所以很多人在生活中行走，却不知道从技术上讲，他们可能正在经历发育性创伤的某些症状。他们可能终其一生都感到：“我真的很焦虑，我不知道为什么，我感到很抑郁，但我并没有什么值得抑郁的事情。”所以当他们第一次进入治疗，我们考虑到发育性创伤时，这能帮助他们把点连成线，让很多事情变得合乎逻辑。请不要认为
that scoring a high score or even maximum score on the ACE scale means that you're, you know, a write-off and there's no chance and you're going to end up in prison because absolutely it doesn't. I have worked with people who score, you know, maximum score on the ACE scale and are incredibly pro-social and, you know, really wouldn't want to hurt anybody or say anything bad or do anything bad to them. So please don't think that I'm condemning you to, you know, a life where you're, you know, not a worthwhile person. That's not at all what I'm saying. But, you know, what the evidence tells us is that life is harder for people who have experienced trauma. And what I found was when we work with people who might be kind of feeling like they've got depression and anxiety or you know they don't feel safe but they don't really know why that other people might be quite invalidating of them there's nothing wrong with you you know it's all in your head and actually
在ACE量表上获得高分甚至满分就意味着你是个“废人”，没有机会了，或者你最终一定会进监狱，因为绝对不是这样。我曾与在ACE量表上获得满分的人一起工作，他们非常具有亲社会性，真的不想伤害任何人，也不想说或做任何坏事。所以请不要认为我是在判定你是一个没有价值的人。我完全不是这个意思。但是，证据告诉我们，经历过创伤的人生活确实更艰难。我发现，当我们与那些可能感到抑郁和焦虑，或者感到不安全却不知道原因的人一起工作时，其他人可能会对他们进行否定，说“你没问题，这都是你心理作用”。但实际上，
when we help people to understand trauma understand what their experiences were you know perhaps if they were all scared of their dad growing up you you know, and if dad was violent growing up or hit mum, this has an impact on people and their lives and it can help them to understand themselves better and it can help them, you know, know that actually there's a reason why they feel like this and can give them, you know, give them an approach and a technique and it can be really validating and really enlightening and help them just recognize, you know, the impact of what they've been through and then to be able to make sense of where they find themselves now and be able to make different choices for themselves and help them to feel safe and calm and soothed and know that they aren't at risk you know imminently anymore and we can help to just turn down that risk alert system that allows them to engage in their life
当我们帮助人们理解创伤，理解他们的经历时——比如如果他们在成长过程中一直害怕父亲，如果父亲有暴力倾向或殴打母亲——这对人们的生活是有影响的。这能帮助他们更好地理解自己，让他们知道自己感到这些是有原因的。这可以为他们提供一种方法和技巧，这非常有验证性且具有启发性，能帮助他们认识到所经历事情的影响，从而理解自己现在的处境，并能够为自己做出不同的选择，帮助他们感到安全、平静和舒缓，知道自己不再处于迫在眉睫的危险之中。我们可以帮助他们调低那个风险警报系统，让他们能够参与到生活中去，
in a way that they might not have done at all before. It can be a real privilege working with people in this way. Okay, we're going to just take a quick break here and I will be back to talk with you about how we can show up for ourselves and our clients when we're working with trauma. Feel better, get on me. Feel better, get on me. Thank you. approach to help reduce anxiety for those who need help the most. It's an online course you can do in your own time and a free weekly webinar session online. Feel Better Academy. Feel Better Academy. So like I said before, we might find ourselves working with people who are traumatized but don't realize that they have experienced trauma. And that can lead to some interesting and powerful conversations and when we go through that
以一种他们以前可能从未有过的方式。以这种方式与人一起工作是一种真正的荣幸。好了，我们在这里休息一下，稍后我会回来与你们探讨在处理创伤时，我们如何为自己和客户提供支持。感觉更好，开始吧。感觉更好，开始吧。谢谢。这种方法有助于减轻那些最需要帮助的人的焦虑。这是一个你可以按照自己的节奏完成的在线课程，还有免费的每周在线网络研讨会。感觉更好学院（Feel Better Academy）。感觉更好学院。正如我之前所说，我们可能会发现自己正在与那些受过创伤却未意识到自己经历过创伤的人一起工作。这可能会引发一些有趣且强有力的对话。当我们与人们一起经历这些时，
with people you might find that they connect to a great deal of sadness about what they've been through and what they've missed out on and what we know is there can be a real overlap between anger and anxiety and sadness and so when we're going through this with people we might find that they also feel angry you know they might find that they feel like really aggrieved that this has been something they've been carrying with them so long or that you know that this has had such an impact on them and it shouldn't have done and it wasn't their fault we might need to help them manage that anger and what we know certainly from working with people in forensic populations is that there can be a real overlap between anxiety and anger so we might find that someone is showing lots of anger and aggression but actually underneath that you, the primary emotion, what comes first is anxiety, you know, it's fear,
你可能会发现他们对所经历的事情、所错失的东西感到非常悲伤。我们知道，愤怒、焦虑和悲伤之间可能存在真正的重叠。所以当我们与人们一起经历这些时，我们可能会发现他们也会感到愤怒。他们可能会觉得非常委屈，因为这是他们长期以来一直背负的东西，或者这对自己产生了如此大的影响，而这本不该发生，也不是他们的错。我们可能需要帮助他们管理这种愤怒。我们从与法医人群的工作中可以确定，焦虑和愤怒之间确实存在重叠。所以我们可能会发现某人表现出大量的愤怒和攻击性，但实际上在内心深处，主要情绪、最先出现的情绪是焦虑，也就是恐惧，
but it wasn't safe to express that or tap into that. And so what comes out is anger, the secondary emotion. And similarly, when we're feeling really anxious, sometimes it can be really useful to think, actually, I think you're really annoyed, you know, I wonder if you're actually really upset about something that's happened, but it doesn't feel safe to express that so that can always be really useful to to tap into that anger and anxiety link and I really like it when people start to tell me off because it can be a real sign that they're getting better so when they are able to assert themselves and when they're able to talk about the things that annoy them and especially when they tell me that I'm annoying them.
但表达或触及这种恐惧并不安全。所以表现出来的是愤怒，即次要情绪。同样，当我们感到非常焦虑时，有时思考一下“我想你其实真的很恼火，我想知道你是否对发生的事情感到非常难过，但表达出来感觉不安全”会非常有帮助。所以触及这种愤怒与焦虑的联系总是非常有用的。当人们开始责备我时，我真的很喜欢，因为这可能是一个他们正在好转的真实迹象。当他们能够主张自己的权利，能够谈论那些让他们恼火的事情，特别是当他们告诉我我让他们感到恼火时。
You know, I tell them at the beginning of therapy, by the time we finish working together, you will tell me how annoying I am. And that's okay. And they're like, no, no, no. No, you're not annoying. There's nothing wrong with you. You know, I absolutely trust everything you say.
你知道，我在治疗开始时告诉他们，当我们结束合作时，你会告诉我我有多烦人。没关系的。他们会说：“不，不，不。你不烦人。你没问题。我绝对相信你说的每一句话。”
You know, and I'd never say you're annoying. And then by the end of our work, you're like, oh, Marianne, you're so annoying. And they're like, yeah, I know, I know. And if you're annoying. And then by the end of our work, you're like, oh, Marianne, you're so annoying. And yeah, I know. I know. And if I do something that's not OK, you know, they're going to have to tell me that. Whereas to begin with, they might be very acquiescent and willing, you know, to let me say what I like, which is where we need to be really careful with our, you know, our power differentials as well to make sure that you know we are being respectful when people are perhaps in a state where they're not able to stick up for themselves and advocate for themselves but with your excellent work you know I really hope that will come
“你知道，我永远不会说你烦人。”然后到我们工作结束时，他们会说：“哦，Marianne，你太烦人了。”他们会说：“是的，我知道，我知道。如果我做了什么不妥的事，他们必须告诉我。”而在开始时，他们可能非常顺从，愿意让我说我想说的任何话。这就是我们需要非常小心权力差异的地方，以确保当人们处于无法为自己挺身而出、无法为自己辩护的状态时，我们依然保持尊重。但通过你们出色的工作，我真的希望这种情况会到来。
and if this stuff is rubbing up against your own wounds then you might find it helpful to check out my Feel Better Academy, which is a place where you can learn to soothe and stabilize yourself and learn to understand why trauma has impacted on you in the way it has and help you, you know, learn skills to feel better and to show up for yourself. If you're an aspiring psychologist but you haven't experienced trauma yourself then the Feel Better Academy is also a really useful way of learning those skills so that you can then use them to help other people because stabilisation work can be so key and so useful and it's an area that aspiring psychologists are often really well placed to be able to step in
如果这些内容触碰到了你自己的伤口，你可能会发现查看我的“感觉更好学院”（Feel Better Academy）很有帮助，这是一个你可以学习如何舒缓和稳定自己，学习理解为什么创伤以这种方式影响你，并帮助你学习技巧以感觉更好并为自己提供支持的地方。如果你是一名有抱负的心理学家，但自己没有经历过创伤，那么“感觉更好学院”也是学习这些技能的非常有用的方式，这样你就可以利用它们来帮助他人，因为稳定化工作非常关键且有用，这是有抱负的心理学家通常非常有能力介入的领域。
and help it might be that you are able to help think about running a stabilization group perhaps or doing some sort of stabilization resources for clients to free up space and capacity for for the qualified psychologists who might be doing you know trauma processing work perhaps so yeah just see how that shakes down in your service. So what we know is we're all just going through our days with the best resources we've got at any given time. And by upskilling ourselves with new resources, we are creating more flexibility for ourselves
并提供帮助。也许你能够考虑组织一个稳定化小组，或者为客户提供某种稳定化资源，从而为可能正在进行创伤处理工作的合格心理学家腾出空间和能力。所以，看看这在你的服务中如何运作。我们知道，我们所有人都在用当时所拥有的最好资源度过每一天。通过用新资源提升自己，我们正在为自己创造更多的灵活性，
and more opportunities to be able to engage more fully with our life and one of the most helpful things we can do at any time of the day really is to check in with ourself and just take a breath so we'll do that together take a breath in through your nose hold it for a moment breathe out through your mouth when you're ready, take a breath in through your nose, hold it for a moment, breathe out through your mouth when you're ready okay and we can do really good things just with that it can help us to re-engage our thinking brain but my children will will start to breathe when I prompt them and sometimes when I don't to help them to you know
以及更多能够更充分地参与生活的机会。在一天中的任何时候，我们能做的最有帮助的事情之一就是审视自己并深呼吸。所以我们一起做一次，通过鼻子吸气，屏住呼吸片刻，准备好时通过嘴呼气。通过鼻子吸气，屏住呼吸片刻，准备好时通过嘴呼气。好的，仅仅通过这一点我们就能做很多好事。它可以帮助我们重新激活我们的思考大脑。我的孩子们在我提示时会开始呼吸，有时在我没提示时也会，以帮助他们
re-engage their wise thinking brains when they might be feeling overwhelmed um uh yeah and sometimes when mummy goes cross they're like mummy i think you need to take a breath so yeah i hope you find i hope you find that useful too and what you will notice is when you help regulate clients that they will come to you in sessions and be like do you realize how many people out there in the world are completely unregulated they are like all over the shop and you'll notice that they start to try to regulate those people so someone I was working with was sharing an office with someone who wasn't managing very well and um you know my client stepped in and said,
在感到不知所措时重新激活他们理智的思考大脑。是的，有时当妈妈生气时，他们会说：“妈妈，我想你需要深呼吸。”所以，希望你也觉得这很有用。你会注意到，当你帮助调节客户时，他们在治疗中会说：“你意识到世界上有多少人完全处于失调状态吗？他们简直乱成一团。”你会注意到他们开始尝试调节那些人。我曾与一位客户一起工作，她与一位状态不佳的同事共用一个办公室，我的客户介入并说：
I think we just need to take a moment just to drop your shoulders and just take some breaths, OK? And then was able to think with the person afterwards about how that felt different. And so, yeah, I love it when people start to teach techniques, you know, outside of the therapy that they know has worked for them um because it's it's a way of getting our psychology message to to be flung far and wide you know so that it's not just the people we're working with um you know i don't think they're all setting themselves up as renegade therapists but they are observing where people would also benefit from the sterling work that they've had so yeah that's when I really like it when people start coming back in and saying
“我想我们需要花点时间，放下肩膀，深呼吸，好吗？”之后她能够与那个人一起思考这种感觉有何不同。所以，是的，我喜欢人们开始教授他们在治疗之外知道对自己有效的技巧，因为这是一种将我们的心理学信息传播得更广的方式。我不认为他们都在把自己设定为叛逆的治疗师，但他们正在观察哪些人也能从他们所获得的卓越工作中受益。所以，当人们回来告诉我时，我真的很喜欢，
oh we did some of that breathing or I did that breathing with my child and they really liked it it really worked you're like yeah well done you so the way that I work with people with trauma is to do stabilization stuff to to use compassion focused therapy, to use the Our Tricky Brain Kit. And then of course, to think about whether we might process any of those traumas with something like EMDR. But actually, sometimes it's enough that people are able to regulate themselves and stabilize themselves and then they don't necessarily need to process the traumas or they don't want to because it kind of keeps things more manageable for them so we don't always need to force clients not that we'd force them to do
“哦，我们做了那种呼吸，或者我和我的孩子做了那种呼吸，他们真的很喜欢，真的很有效。”你会说：“是的，做得好。”我处理创伤的方式是进行稳定化工作，使用同情心聚焦疗法（CFT），使用“棘手大脑工具包”（Tricky Brain Kit）。当然，还要考虑我们是否可能用EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）等方法处理这些创伤。但实际上，有时人们能够调节和稳定自己就足够了，他们不一定需要处理创伤，或者他们不想处理，因为这能让事情对他们来说更可控。所以我们并不总是需要强迫客户——当然我们不会强迫他们做
anything of course but we don't need to you know processing trauma is not always the holy grail you know absolutely we can be client-led and it might be that clients come to you for a chapter of therapy you know they come to you for the stabilization and then once they're used to tolerating their distress and tolerating the ideas and they're not judging themselves for their for their thoughts and they're not feeling as you know full of shame or guilt then then they might be ready to start thinking about processing. But, you know, actually what we're looking for is to alleviate distress. And so if the client is freer from distress, then they might never want to or need to process those traumas. It might be that they've had enough or had as much as they need, certainly for for now so whatever branch of aspiring psychologist you are
任何事情——但我们不需要……处理创伤并不总是终极目标。我们绝对可以以客户为中心。可能客户来找你进行一段治疗，他们来找你进行稳定化，一旦他们习惯了忍受痛苦和想法，不再因为自己的想法而评判自己，不再感到充满羞耻或内疚，那么他们可能就准备好开始考虑处理创伤了。但实际上，我们寻求的是减轻痛苦。所以如果客户从痛苦中解脱出来，他们可能永远不需要处理那些创伤。可能他们已经经历得够多了，或者至少目前已经足够了。所以无论你是哪种有抱负的心理学家，
i hope you found this useful um as ever if you are watching on youtube please do like this video leave me a little comment pop um sun with some glasses on as an emoji so that i know that you've listened right to the end that would mean a great deal to me. And do subscribe and click that notification bell to be notified when I drop new content into YouTube. And if you are listening on another podcast platform, then yeah, please do subscribe because then I will drop into your into your library every Monday at 6 a.m. what is not to like about that thank you again for being part of my world and listening right to the end enjoy this jingle because I know that I will take care and have a lovely day. Without a merry entrance My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
希望你觉得这很有用。一如既往，如果你是在YouTube上观看，请点赞这个视频，给我留个小评论，放一个戴墨镜的太阳表情符号，这样我就知道你听到了最后，这对我很重要。请订阅并点击通知铃铛，以便在我在YouTube发布新内容时收到通知。如果你是在其他播客平台上收听，请务必订阅，这样我每周一早上6点就会出现在你的库里。这有什么不好呢？再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分并听到最后。享受这段叮当声吧，因为我知道我会的。保重，祝你有美好的一天。我是Marianne Trent。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。目前还没有关于这期节目的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。